the counting has begun after the end of
a contentious referendum
malians were asked to vote Yes or no to
a new Constitution that seeks to unite a
country deeply divided since the 2021
military coup that brought mali's Junta
to power
looking to get his voice heard is 76
year old retired electrician Abdul Karim
konate he says he has never missed a
vote since mali's Independence he's
voting yes to a new Constitution that
gives more autonomy to Regions
democracy is since the third Republic
has not really worked this vote I
believe will help to bring back
stability to the country those voting no
say the proposed secular text fails to
recognize the role of Islam in this
muslim-majority country and it brings
little oversight to the nation's leader
the new texts will give substantially
more power to the head of state and this
is worrying
has been encouraging people to come out
and vote he believes a new constitution
is a step towards finding peace in a
country torn by War
I am calling on all malians no matter
the outcome of this referendum to stay
hand in hand for the sake of our sacred
Unity arm groups linked to Al-Qaeda and
isil had called for a boycott of the
referendum threatening attacks against
polling stations many malians have been
too afraid to cast their votes
braving the threat is Fatima tadiko with
her eight-year-old daughter I am voting
because it is my responsibility as a
citizen and I believe the country will
find peace if we all come out and
express ourselves
for the last 30 years past presidents
have failed to change a constitution
copied from France the former colonial
power
we are not French we have our own
culture our own values we have our own
sovereignty our own way of living
together and this is what it's all about
let's take a look at inside the polling
stations there are the usual ballot
papers the assessors the voting booths
but missing are the independent
International observers the Mali
military Junta says it does not need
Outsiders to bring credibility to a vote
that concerns the Malian people
for konate
and Eco this is more than a referendum
at stake is the future of democracy in
Mali a vote that will either unite or
further divide the Malian people
Nicholas honk Al Jazeera obamaco